I've played classical guitars for like
15 16 years and so like to feel these
Frets that I'm so used to on loots and
things on a guitar it just feels strange
hey friends welcome back to the channel
I am back today at Marshall brene's
showroom here it is fantastic shop
Marshall how you doing great yourself
good we are uh both pretty excited today
because we are doing a very nerdy
experiment oh yeah yeah when you brought
the idea up I I couldn't resist and upon
execution I personally couldn't stop
laughing because I just
it it hurt my head and and tickled my
senses all at the same time so the thing
that's really getting us excited is that
we are going to put gut Frets on a
classical guitar yeah modern Spanish
style classical guitar definitely
blasphemy but uh hey
what are notes for this is great oh yeah
this is a lot of fun
now if you don't already know here's a
quick little history lesson uh all
guitars today are fitted with metal
Frets Frets are these pieces of metal
placed periodically over the fingerboard
that help us stop pitches and allow us
to play chords now
4 1800 this was not how guitars were
fretted in fact before each 100 they
used the same material as they used for
Strings so this is a baroque Guitar
model adapter a 1600s the bone which has
gut strings and the same material got is
now wrapped around the back of the neck
here so the Frets are tight on rather
than fixed
[Music]
so Marshall why do you think they used
guts for the Frets and for the strings
these strings were frightfully expensive
and they still are to this day
exceptionally expensive and so to
prolong the lifespan of the strings
instead of putting metal or or some wood
or something else like that they used
gut because the two together wouldn't
wear each other out but ultimately it
was because the cost of the gut strings
for a loot
was in excess of the price of the loot
per year that's why they use gut frets
amazing okay now as mentioned before
today metal Frets are common but when
exactly did that happen and my
understanding is that guitars and loots
basically before 1800 more or less the
guitars that I play the theorbos loots
Etc
um had these nice gut Frets which have
advantages by the way we'll get to that
later but around 1800 you have a new
style guitar being made the birth of the
six single string guitar
[Music]
and uh gradually it started being made
with metal Frets and it seems like from
there on up they just kind of stuck with
metal Frets and even they they switched
the pegs to gradually to uh those like
clock gear yeah right is that is that
correct yeah as far as the Frets go they
realized hey you know tying on these
Frets is really time consuming it's
annoying so I might as well just go with
this I love the the sound of this guitar
very mellow yeah it's mellow and Punchy
all at the same time this is a good
example of when these metal Frets start
becoming more ubiquitous but today we're
not here to do what's historical we're
here to break the rules and put some gut
Frets on a classical guitar so I'd say
we should do it yes let's so we headed
over to Marshall's shop where we found
his classical guitar which Had No Frets
and next we found his rather large
collection of gut strings
this is of course sheep intestine which
historically guitarists and lutinists
use for Strings and Frets then one by
one we tied on each fret onto the neck
of the guitar utilizing a standard fret
knot there are two ways of securing the
knot normally early plucked players just
use fire we burn the ends but since this
was a guitar that was going to a client
Marshall preferred to use a bit of glue
then you just clip the excess gut Slide
the Fret down into place voila we have
gut Frets on a classical guitar
are we are we friends are we ready to go
yeah we're friends we're ready to go
oh my God
here we have it
it looks so wrong and so right at the
same time it does it does I you know I
couldn't stop laughing at this
I've played classical guitars for like
15 16 years and so like to feel these
Frets that I'm so used to on loots and
things now like a guitar it just feels
strange yes the glisten windows are
going to be very interesting to say at
least let's play this thing and see how
it sounds
[Music]
sounds like a guitar sounds very guitar
so clearly they work I mean if it didn't
work they wouldn't have used them for
hundreds and hundreds of years right
right right right right
[Music]
well I mean it plays like a guitar
sounds like guitar to be honest I could
really see myself getting used to these
gut Frets because it's not that strange
you know I think coming from classical
guitar maybe the first hour you're with
a gut fret guitar you're kind of
freaking out because your your thumb is
like bumping up over all of these ridges
here and it feels super strange yeah but
it also has its benefits because you can
probably do away with the dots because
all you have to do is count one to three
four five six seven
[Laughter]
it's true you do feel these on the back
of the neck and uh looking at it is a
different experience than metal facts
it's a less clean uh look uh but you
know uh it's funny because I'm feeling
this total like uh funny moment of
knowing Both Worlds but having them at
the same time is just uh is a little
weird so it's like having ice cream on
top of your steak that's exactly how I
feel right now
oh
foreign
[Music]
okay so I'm already loving this this
whole experiment here uh have you ever
put gut Frets in the classical guitar
before no not at all uh this is the
first time anybody has ever said hey can
you take gut Frets and put it onto a
Spanish classical guitar we're talking
about almost 60 years of of actual
working time so this is a one-time thing
unless this takes off and I'm going to
start to get a lot of requests
you know the things I do Brandon I know
man lots and lots of favors
[Laughter]
so what do you think what's your what's
your take on the result it's hilarious
it's fun uh it definitely doesn't sound
like how I expect this guitar to sound
interesting uh it's missing uh something
that the metal Frets typically add which
is what I designed for this is actually
what I wanted to ask you because later
in this video we're going to put metal
Flats on this guitar because he's going
to finish the instrument as it was
intended but I want to talk to you about
this because I want to make a prediction
here and see what we what happens here
okay my prediction was gonna be that the
gut Frets and the metal Frets were going
to sound the same on the instrument
because I've played so many instruments
we've got Frets and they sound really
good and in my head they're not going to
sound better with metal threads but you
seem to think that this is going to
sound better with metal Frets I wonder
is that true and why oh well so I
believe it's going to so actually I know
it's going to sound better with metal
Frets because this is designed to have
metal Frets there's a response or a
reflection of the note the the impulse
from the string against the Fret which
reflects back into the body so I build
guitars with a little bit more uh
impedance or restraint than what these
gut string guitars are built for
and because these Frets are not firmly
affixed every time the impulse comes up
and hits this
a little bit of extra energy is lost in
the movement of this of the Fret
wow
okay well it blowing my mind uh I'll be
very eager to get those metal Frets on
it and try this thing so our idea here
now is I'm going to play a a short
excerpt or two and then uh later I guess
in in a few weeks or so when Marshall
puts the the metal Frets on I'll come
back and record and we're going to
compare the end of this video and see
how it sounds sounds good cool
today's video is brought to you by
classical guitar Pro that's my brand new
online classical guitar course which is
six hours 53 videos it's a whole
curriculum designed to teach you what
you would normally learn in the first
six months to a year of classical guitar
lessons so if you want to learn
classical guitar but are stuck
struggling reading music or struggling
to learn the techniques check out
classical guitar dashpro.com to learn
more
we're back here a few weeks later at
Marshall shop and now the guitar that
had gut Frets on it officially is
completed for the the client who
Marshall is making the guitar for in the
first place and now I'm very excited to
find out how this thing sounds with
metal Frets yeah yeah it was a it was a
lot of fun getting it ready that was
gratifying to see a guitar as it comes
together yeah I bet looks beautiful and
let's let's find out how it feels
foreign
[Music]
feels like a great guitar Marshall thank
you smoother way smoother so far I think
I played some different scales on it and
some chords on it before let's just go
ahead and test test those out
[Music]
let's also try I think I tried some some
chords I want to test those out
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
so right off the bat my first thought is
metal Frets are always so reliable
especially when done by a great luthier
like yourself I think last time we went
into some trouble with the gut Frets and
it wasn't exactly a fair comparison
because the the slots for the Frets were
already cut and so I think the gut Frets
were like falling into those slots and
it was making it really hard to get a
clean sound it kind of a little bit
Buzzy which is not normally the case so
I think this experiment wasn't totally
fair I actually I'm a big fan of gut
Frets um but uh now seeing them you know
with metal threads of course it feels
more reliable and I know it's not going
to buzz so that's at least nice now what
are you noticing about the sound of this
guitar from the last time to now so I
was thinking about that let me let me
play I played a little excerpt from uh
from a sword piece let me play it as
well and get a better sense of what's
okay what's going on
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yeah what I'm noticing is that this
thing has more sustain
I that it just it feels like it has very
clean resonance and again with the
caveat that we didn't have the perfect
experiment perfect perfect comparison
between gut Frets that were really tight
on as they normally would be without the
slots filed
um here I'm finding that there's a kind
of like a singing quality throughout any
of the Frets and everything sounds good
everything sounds resonant and it's
really singing a lot more than it did
with our gut experiment yeah well I mean
it really goes to show that instruments
nowadays are truly designed for these
types of strings with these types of
Frets that too whereas the instruments
that typically have a gut fret are
designed for gut fret to give the
appropriate response yeah so if you put
a metal fret into a gut fret instrument
it's going to sound garrish and overly
rot with with the sound right well
congrats on the beautiful guitar thank
you I think my conclusion here is that
for classical guitars I'm happy to play
as they did with metal Frets and uh for
my early plucked instruments I'm I'm
definitely not tempted to go to metal
Frets I think you know they both had the
right setup for the job yep yeah and as
a maker I'm happy to continue putting
metal Frets in and don't anybody ask me
for gut frets
just because of this video
you'll see the anti-promo code later
right
so thank you guys for watching I hope it
was as fun to watch as it was to
experiment with here in the shop
um Marshall did you want to add anything
yeah
um for 500 off of any new guitar deposit
uh just type in promo code Brandon and
on my website and you'll get 500 off
great thanks again Marshall we'll see
you guys next time
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]